Theodor Steiner: So, I'm not used to doing this introduction in English because usually this podcast is in Japanese. So, bear with me if it's a lot of ums and errs, but this is the UIT Inside podcast. UIT is the front-end organization at LY Corporation, which is a Japanese company, and our major products are the LINE Messenger, which is the leading messenger in Japan, and Yahoo Japan, which is the Japanese version of the Yahoo search engine. And today I'm really excited because we have the most amazing guest ever on. We have Dan Abramov on the podcast. Dan, can you introduce yourself?
Dan Abramov: Hi, thank you. My name is Dan. I guess I used to work on React, so that's how you might have seen my avatar on GitHub sometimes. And then I used to work at Bluesky. And now I'm working part-time on the Next.js team at Vercel.
Theodor Steiner: And you work for Vercel Japan, is that right?
Dan Abramov: That's the plan. So currently I'm still in the UK, but I submitted the visa documents. So we'll see how that comes through, but the plan is to relocate to Japan, possibly at the end of the—
Theodor Steiner: That would be so cool. And you're always welcome at our office.
Dan Abramov: Thank you.
Theodor Steiner: By the way, the visa documents can take quite some time. I applied for permanent residency in Japan 16 months ago... so.
Dan Abramov: Okay. That's—haha. Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: But I hope you can get fast-tracked.
Dan Abramov: I hope so.
Theodor Steiner: Yeah. And obviously I had you introduce yourself, but you don't really need an introduction. When I told my colleagues that you were going to come on the show, they were all so excited.
Theodor Steiner: So, you're not just famous in the English-speaking world, but every Japanese front-end developer also knows you.
Dan Abramov: Oh, interesting. Because I thought people already kind of... because I disappeared a little bit from the scene. I think there's a new generation who... I haven't really talked too much.
Theodor Steiner: Yeah, I guess there's a new generation as well, but you're still the legend, I guess.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: So we had a meeting last Thursday, and I was like, "Yeah, Dan is coming on." And they all spammed the chat with emojis because they were so excited. And I've never had that happen with a guest coming on before.
Dan Abramov: Oh, cool. Well, appreciate it.
Theodor Steiner: But today we're not talking about React.
Theodor Steiner: We're actually here to talk about something completely different, which is the ATProto protocol. So, ATProto—what does ATProto even stand for?
Dan Abramov: Ah, ATProto. It's like "AT Protocol," and "AT" supposedly stands for "Authenticated Transfer." So I think that's kind of the formal name. I think really the reason is because it looks like the @ symbol that you use in usernames, and it's a protocol that has to do with identity. So it's kind of like when you say my Instagram handle is @whatever, except it's an internet protocol instead of something specific to a company.
Theodor Steiner: Okay. So you and I are both on Bluesky, so I think we have quite a bit of contact with the AT Protocol. But the majority of Japanese developers are still stuck on Twitter or X, and they might have never heard of AT Protocol.
Dan Abramov: Mhm.
Theodor Steiner: Can you just give us the 100-foot bird's-eye view of the protocol? What is that?
Dan Abramov: Yeah, it's very tricky to answer because a good protocol stays invisible. It's a way to build social apps—not necessarily social, but I guess that's an easier area to focus on.
Dan Abramov: It's a new way to build social apps that was originally developed by Bluesky, the company that you might know as a Twitter clone product. But really, originally they were supposed to do that with Twitter itself. It's just that Twitter broke the contract with them.
Dan Abramov: But the thing they originally wanted to build is a generic, universal internet protocol. I've tried to describe it in different ways. I don't know which one resonates. Different audiences understand it differently.
Dan Abramov: One way I would describe it to web developers is that it tries to extract an identity layer for the web. So each app has its own login, and for social apps you can create different kinds of things in the app, but they stay within that app, right?
Dan Abramov: Like if I write an answer on Stack Overflow, it's kind of stuck inside Stack Overflow. If I write a comment on GitHub, it's kind of stuck inside GitHub, in the sense that these companies own what I made using their products.
Dan Abramov: And then if these companies start changing in ways that you don't like, maybe you can abandon them, but you've invested so much effort and so much content into these closed spaces that they control.
Dan Abramov: And the idea of AT Protocol, or shorter, ATProto, is to kind of lift that out so that everything works more like files.
Dan Abramov: So when I post on Bluesky, I'm not actually putting stuff into the Bluesky app. Although it looks like this, right? If you just use it, it kind of looks like Twitter. Or if you use Tangled, which is ATProto's GitHub alternative, it kind of looks like GitHub.
Dan Abramov: But what happens behind the scenes is actually it's almost like I have a folder somewhere in the cloud that has data from all of these apps as JSON.
Dan Abramov: So everything is stored as JSON in this new layer of the web that is app agnostic. It's not controlled by one company necessarily, right? You can host this folder with different providers. You can host it yourself. It is really cheap.
Dan Abramov: But it's app agnostic, and as a result anyone can start a competitor to one of these services or one of these apps with all existing data already there and already interoperable with existing apps.
Dan Abramov: So if somebody wants to start a competitor to Bluesky—and this actually happened—there's Blacksky, which has different moderation policies and so on, but it's completely interoperable with the Bluesky app even though it doesn't use the Bluesky API.
Dan Abramov: So that is the big thing. Every app on ATProto shares a common API where you don't need to provide an API as the app author because all apps just write to this JSON.
Dan Abramov: It's a common way for apps to, in a sense, talk to each other—or show content from each other and augment each other—without actually talking to each other. So without exposing an API, because the protocol itself is the API.
Dan Abramov: There's a few other ways I like to explain it, but I think that's the big idea: freeing the stuff that we create, lifting it out of apps, and making it live on an independent layer that we actually control as users, so that everything we create is more like files under the hood, but with the same normal user experience for the app user.
Theodor Steiner: And you actually have a great blog post on this. You have "A Social File System" on your blog, Overreacted, and it talks about what you just did the perfect summary of.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: Actually, we can just end the podcast here.
Theodor Steiner: But I think we want to dive a bit deeper, and since this podcast is mostly for web developers, I actually prepared a little ambush for you.
Theodor Steiner: So, ATProto is a protocol, and web developers are usually familiar with the HTTP protocol. So I sort of wanted to go up the stack layer by layer and see where they differ, what ATProto offers on top of HTTP, and how they even build on each other.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: And this might feel like a check of your HTTP knowledge, but we'll keep it real simple and easy.
Theodor Steiner: So, layer zero of HTTP is: what is HTTP even for? It would be a communication standard between clients and servers. And you already hinted at this, but what is layer zero behind the ATProto protocol?
Dan Abramov: Yeah. ATProto kind of builds on top of multiple things. It builds on top of HTTP, DNS, JSON, WebSockets, CBOR, and I think maybe these are the ones that I know.
Dan Abramov: I'm sure there are other things, but it's HTTP or WebSockets as the transport, and then CBOR as encoding, I think, for JSON, and then DNS for a bunch of...
Theodor Steiner: So it doesn't really try to reinvent anything about how the internet works.
Dan Abramov: Right.
Theodor Steiner: It sort of builds on top of the existing transport layer of the internet.
Dan Abramov: Yeah. And I guess it has a few of its own inventions. There's something called Lexicon, which is a JSON type definition. They did not go with RDF or JSON-LD or JSON Schema. They made their own because none of these things quite fit what they wanted.
Dan Abramov: So there are some custom pieces, but where appropriate it tries to reuse existing primitives.
Dan Abramov: For example, domains as handles is one example. Instead of inventing its own handle system, it's like, well, it has to be centralized in some sense, because somebody has to determine the top-level mappings, like who owns this username. And they decided, well, this already exists on the internet. It's called domains. So we're just going to use this existing system for this.
Dan Abramov: I think there's a lot of that in the design.
Dan Abramov: And then there's also cryptography. In addition to all of this stuff, there's cryptography—not in the sense of crypto, blockchain, or whatever, even though there is one element that's maybe reminiscent of that. We can get to that if we want to.
Dan Abramov: But overall it's much more like the web. There are cryptographic signatures and public-key/private-key cryptography.
Theodor Steiner: The math part of cryptography.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: So whereas HTTP—HTTP and ATProto both have URIs. For HTTP, everyone in the web world knows URLs. You have a domain that maps to a server, and DNS helps resolve the path to the server.
Theodor Steiner: But in the ATProto world, what is the common URI? What is in there?
Dan Abramov: So in ATProto, all AT URIs...
Dan Abramov: First, it's worth talking about the AT URI itself. It's `at://`, and then what goes after it?
Dan Abramov: I think the first question is: what does it point to?
Dan Abramov: An HTTP URI points at a song, an image, an HTML page, or something like this. Maybe that HTML page has more links.
Dan Abramov: In ATProto, all AT URIs point at records. And a record is a piece of JSON with a typed schema.
Dan Abramov: Essentially, every AT URI points at some JSON.
Dan Abramov: For example, a Bluesky post is a piece of JSON. Or Tangled—the GitHub alternative—a star is also a piece of JSON. A Bluesky follow is a piece of JSON that says you follow this person.
Dan Abramov: So it's the stuff that you create: these documents, or records, through the apps.
Dan Abramov: These records can link to each other.
Dan Abramov: For example, if I comment on your post, each of us has a folder, or a repo, where all of our stuff lives. The important part is that you have yours and I have mine.
Dan Abramov: Each of us owns our own data.
Dan Abramov: Sure, maybe we use some hosting behind the scenes. When I sign up for Bluesky, I don't think about where it lives. But I actually moved my hosting, so you can move it over time.
Dan Abramov: All my stuff is in my repo, and all your stuff is in your repo.
Dan Abramov: Actually, I'm going to give you a test to see if you understand it.
Dan Abramov: If 10,000 people follow you, where do these follow records live?
Dan Abramov: Are they in your repo, or are they somewhere else?
Theodor Steiner: I would say they are distributed across 10,000 users, right?
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: Because everyone holds their own follow.
Dan Abramov: Yeah, exactly.
Dan Abramov: So if you have a million followers, they're not actually yours. There's one follow record per person who follows you.
Dan Abramov: But if you follow a million people, that's a million records in your repo, because it was your choice to follow them.
Dan Abramov: So now that we understand your stuff lives in your repo and my stuff lives in mine, if I comment on your posts, that's a comment record in my repo that has a link to posts in your repo.
Dan Abramov: And that's where AT URIs come in. I need a way to link to something that exists in your repo—to some piece of JSON.
Dan Abramov: So we have this web of JSON where, instead of HTML pages with links, we have JSON with links.
Dan Abramov: That's where the need for a separate protocol comes up.
Dan Abramov: If we just used HTTP, imagine there's some server hosting your data at `hosting-company.com/you/post`, and I link to that from my repo. That means you can never change the hosting company without breaking the link.
Dan Abramov: We have the domain system, which lets whoever hosts the content change where it's hosted—change the IP address—but it doesn't let you move away from that hosting company without breaking the links, because it's still hosted by `hosting-company.com`.
Dan Abramov: From a product-design perspective, that is the big reason why everything went wrong.
Dan Abramov: We put stuff into these apps, into these boxes, and then it stays there because they have power over us.
Dan Abramov: So coming back to your question: what is in the AT Protocol link?
Dan Abramov: It also starts with a domain authority.
Dan Abramov: You may see something like `at://dabra.ms/...`.
Dan Abramov: But the important part is that the first thing is not where it's hosted.
Dan Abramov: It's not the physical server. It's not the domain for the physical server. It's my username, in a sense.
Dan Abramov: So there is an extra resolution step where we find out, okay, for this username, where is the current server where this is hosted?
Dan Abramov: Then it goes to HTTP to fetch it.
Dan Abramov: So it's one indirection that puts usernames before the physical storage.
Dan Abramov: That lets me change where my actual hosting is over time, and none of the links will break.
Dan Abramov: That's the big motivation for why it's done this way.
Theodor Steiner: So if I rephrase this in my own words: the issue with HTTP is that it uses URLs, and URLs point at locations. The issue is that those locations can change—they're sort of ephemeral.
Theodor Steiner: But ATProto says we somehow need this to never change. We need some resource identifier that will always point at your repo.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Dan Abramov: Or you could say that it literally puts people first.
Dan Abramov: In a URL, the authority part is the physical host of the location.
Dan Abramov: In an AT URI—and there's a whole tangent about whether it should technically be called a URI—but essentially the authority part is the user themselves.
Dan Abramov: So it's not like `bluesky.com/danabra...`; it's `dabra.ms/...`.
Dan Abramov: It inverts the relationship so that the user comes first.
Dan Abramov: There's one nuance I wanted to flag.
Dan Abramov: When we talk about the username, that's the friendly way to write an AT URI.
Dan Abramov: But it's actually unstable because you can change your username over time.
Dan Abramov: The full form of the URI starts with something called a DID, which is a permanent identifier that never changes.
Dan Abramov: So this is the thing that's forever immutable, as long as you're in control of your identity.
Theodor Steiner: Okay, I want to come back to the DID part because I think it's really important. I didn't know it was pronounced "did"—no pun intended.
Theodor Steiner: So to get this back to the HTTP discussion: in HTTP you have a domain. You could perhaps lose access to your domain, and the domain sort of allows you to obfuscate where your data actually lives. But you could lose the domain, and that's the issue.
Theodor Steiner: And to solve that, the AT Protocol adds a different layer that says, "No, the domain, or your server, is not what we're looking for. The identity is what we're looking for. And if we have your identity, we can resolve that to where you host in HTTP."
Dan Abramov: Yes. I wouldn't say it's because you can lose it, although certainly you can lose a domain.
Dan Abramov: I think it's more about... if we're talking about something like a tweet, it's not going to live on your domain anyway. It lives on Twitter.
Dan Abramov: So if we try to design this thing with HTTP, then the HTTP URI would be something like `twitter.com` or `twitter-data-storage.com`, or whatever.
Dan Abramov: But then the problem is you can't walk away from Twitter and use a different app. You can't get rid of Twitter without breaking all these links.
Dan Abramov: It's more about how, when each of us had our own site, we were directly connected to how the internet works. If we don't like the hosting, we just change our hosting. Our users don't need to know—it still resolves.
Dan Abramov: But when we moved into social spaces like Facebook, Twitter, or Stack Overflow, we're now one step disconnected from how the internet actually works because we can't change our hosting.
Dan Abramov: You can't change your hosting when you're using Twitter. Twitter couples the app and the hosting.
Dan Abramov: And so the idea here is: let's still make your content live in a different world where you can change the hosting, it's app agnostic, and the app is just one of the consumers of this layer of the internet.
Dan Abramov: In that sense, I like to think about it as similar to RSS and Google Reader.
Dan Abramov: You control your RSS. You can move where you host it, and then you can consume all of the RSS you're interested in from apps such as Google Reader.
Dan Abramov: But they actually have no sway on the underlying system. If Google Reader disappears, somebody else can make an RSS client that reads from all of them.
Dan Abramov: So it's really about avoiding lock-in. It's about removing the power from the apps to keep you locked down.
Theodor Steiner: That's a really nice way of putting it.
Theodor Steiner: And now that we know the promise of the AT Protocol, I kind of want to dive into how it works.
Theodor Steiner: So you said there's this DID that can be resolved to your identity.
Theodor Steiner: For HTTP, the domain would be resolved to your location via DNS.
Theodor Steiner: You do a DNS lookup and you get the IP address.
Theodor Steiner: How is the DID resolved to you?
Dan Abramov: Yeah. So let's first start with what a DID is.
Dan Abramov: This is a W3C standard. They tried to reuse this part.
Dan Abramov: It's kind of a meta-standard in the sense that it doesn't actually specify how to resolve a DID.
Dan Abramov: It's more like a DID is a format where first it says `did:`, and then there's something called the DID method.
Dan Abramov: This can be three letters—or maybe more—but the method specifies how to find a certain thing: a piece of JSON that's your identity.
Dan Abramov: From that point, the rest is just an identifier for this method.
Dan Abramov: So it's almost like DID is just a universal umbrella for many identity systems.
Dan Abramov: ATProto picks two DID systems supported by the DID standard because they satisfy certain properties.
Dan Abramov: One property is that they have to be fast to resolve.
Dan Abramov: Something like "download the whole blockchain" is already a non-starter.
Dan Abramov: It has to be something that's easily resolvable.
Dan Abramov: I don't remember the exact properties, but they basically picked two things.
Dan Abramov: One is the one they invented.
Dan Abramov: There are two DID methods supported by ATProto.
Dan Abramov: One is called `did:plc`, which initially stood for "placeholder" because they thought they were going to replace it. Then they decided, "Actually, it's quite good. We're going to keep it."
Dan Abramov: Now it's supposedly "Public Ledger of Credentials."
Theodor Steiner: Okay, that's a crypto-like ledger.
Dan Abramov: Yeah. I think that is an influence from that world.
Dan Abramov: But it's actually not distributed.
Dan Abramov: This is the centralized part.
Dan Abramov: It's kind of like an npm registry.
Dan Abramov: The other DID method is `did:web`, which uses a normal domain lookup.
Dan Abramov: So these are two ways this can work.
Dan Abramov: In both cases, the goal is to resolve to a piece of JSON that is called your DID document, which I kind of like to think of as a passport.
Dan Abramov: It's a piece of JSON that says three things.
Dan Abramov: One is where your stuff currently lives—your HTTP hosting.
Dan Abramov: Another is your handle—your domain username.
Dan Abramov: It can be completely different from where it's hosted.
Dan Abramov: The third thing is your public key.
Dan Abramov: So if somebody wants to verify some record, what is the public key that they verify against?
Dan Abramov: These are the two methods.
Dan Abramov: The difference between them is that one is more centralized.
Dan Abramov: Legally, they're spinning it off into an independent Swiss organization.
Dan Abramov: The goal is for it to evolve similarly to how the root DNS has evolved with ICANN, with some neutral organization managing it.
Dan Abramov: Being centralized is kind of the point, because that is the authoritative place to say what's under this identity.
Dan Abramov: But they came up with a bunch of things that make it less of a problem that it's centralized.
Dan Abramov: For example, it's entirely open source.
Dan Abramov: There is no private state in it.
Dan Abramov: It's fully replayable based on public data.
Dan Abramov: You can audit it.
Dan Abramov: There's an audit log.
Dan Abramov: You can inspect every transaction.
Dan Abramov: It's highly auditable.
Dan Abramov: That's the usual way.
Dan Abramov: If you sign up on Bluesky, you're going to get a `did:plc` identity.
Dan Abramov: PLC is the thing that holds your DID document.
Dan Abramov: But if you hate the idea of anything centralized, there's `did:web`, where the identifier is literally a domain instead of a hash.
Dan Abramov: With `did:plc` you get a hash.
Dan Abramov: With `did:web` you get a domain.
Dan Abramov: But if you lose the domain, you can't control your identity anymore—it effectively dies.
Dan Abramov: So that's kind of the choice for hardcore decentralizers.
Theodor Steiner: So the PLC directory is a centralized place to look up DIDs that use the PLC method.
Theodor Steiner: And "Public Ledger" sort of implies that there's a way I can look up the ledger.
Theodor Steiner: I can see what happened on the ledger, and "public" means probably everyone can look it up.
Theodor Steiner: Can I just do an HTTP request somewhere and get information about my ID?
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Dan Abramov: There is something called the PLC directory.
Dan Abramov: It's a website.
Dan Abramov: It has an example where DID resolution can be as simple as:
Dan Abramov: `curl https://plc.directory/`
Dan Abramov: and that gives you your JSON.
Dan Abramov: So there's an API.
Dan Abramov: There's also an API for retrieving past versions.
Dan Abramov: You can see, for every DID document, what it says now and what it said in the past.
Dan Abramov: You can verify that each change is signed by the public key from the previous version of the DID document.
Dan Abramov: So you can independently verify that the DID document could not have been tampered with, because it's signed by the user's private key, which the PLC directory doesn't have.
Dan Abramov: And then the first version of the DID document, when hashed, that hash is your identifier on PLC.
Dan Abramov: So you can verify that the first version is also correct because it has the signature.
Dan Abramov: It's a hash of the signed version of the first document.
Dan Abramov: So you can recursively verify, for every user, the entire chain of changes to their identity, including changes to hosting, the key pair, and the username.
Theodor Steiner: So it's a cryptographically verifiable chain of events of what happened to your passport, so to say, with no loose ends, because the first entry is the DID itself—the identifier itself.
Dan Abramov: Yes.
Theodor Steiner: Okay.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: Very cool.
Theodor Steiner: And you said there are three parts living in there.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: There's your alias, there's where your data lives...
Dan Abramov: Mhm.
Theodor Steiner: ...and then what was the last part?
Dan Abramov: The public key.
Theodor Steiner: The public key. Okay.
Theodor Steiner: So people can verify that it's actually what it claims to be.
Theodor Steiner: So where does the data actually live?
Theodor Steiner: What would be in my DID document?
Dan Abramov: So it depends on how you made your ATProto account.
Dan Abramov: We call this layer above the web the "atmosphere."
Dan Abramov: So having an atmosphere account is kind of like having a Google account, except it's the web.
Dan Abramov: I think that's part of the idea—that we all just have these web accounts instead of many accounts tied to a specific provider like Google.
Dan Abramov: If you follow the DID document, it will say...
Dan Abramov: For example, if I sign up for ATProto through the Bluesky app, it has to create hosting for me because I don't already have ATProto hosting.
Dan Abramov: Bluesky is actually two different things.
Dan Abramov: There's Bluesky hosting under the hood, and there's the Bluesky app. They're completely independent.
Dan Abramov: I actually changed my hosting to a different provider.
Dan Abramov: You can also self-host. You can run a server yourself. It's really cheap.
Dan Abramov: If you sign up through Bluesky, it's going to point to something like `*.host.bsky.network` or whatever.
Dan Abramov: This is the server that hosts your JSON, contains your private key, and is able to serve your data.
Dan Abramov: If apps want to know what you've posted, it can serve your posts and all the other information from other atmosphere apps.
Dan Abramov: It also provides a WebSocket connection for notifying about changes.
Dan Abramov: That's why this whole thing works in real time.
Dan Abramov: It's not just pull.
Dan Abramov: Apps subscribe to your hosting, and they're notified when something changes so they can immediately ingest it and put it into their databases.
Theodor Steiner: So for the traditional web, this would be, for example, the Twitter server.
Theodor Steiner: I want to post something to Twitter, and it goes to the Twitter server.
Theodor Steiner: But in ATProto, this is the PDS part, right? The Personal Data Server.
Dan Abramov: Yeah. Yes.
Theodor Steiner: And my data only lives on one server.
Theodor Steiner: So it's like a one-to-one mapping between my DID document and the PDS.
Dan Abramov: Yeah. Your data always points to one.
Dan Abramov: I mean, one server can serve many users' data, right?
Dan Abramov: It scales, but your own stuff only lives in one place.
Dan Abramov: At least the source of truth.
Dan Abramov: Of course, apps consume it and have their own local caches or databases, but the source of truth is your PDS.
Theodor Steiner: So I think I'm actually on the same PDS as you.
Theodor Steiner: I'm German, and I moved to eurosky.social.
Dan Abramov: Mhm. Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: I think that's the PDS.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: And I did a migration and everything.
Theodor Steiner: I think that's the interesting part you talked about earlier.
Theodor Steiner: Since your identity stays in one place, you can switch where your data lives and everything follows it around.
Theodor Steiner: So I had a Bluesky account.
Theodor Steiner: Initially, signing up left me with the default Bluesky PDS.
Theodor Steiner: Then I made a bunch of posts, a bunch of likes, followed, of course, Dan Abramov on Bluesky...
Theodor Steiner: And then at some point I wanted to move that to Europe.
Theodor Steiner: What happened behind the scenes when I did the migration?
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Dan Abramov: The first thing that happened is that your entire repository—all of your JSON—was copied.
Dan Abramov: If you're familiar with Git, it's kind of like pushing Git to a different remote.
Dan Abramov: Your repository has been pushed to another place.
Dan Abramov: You also had to migrate your media.
Dan Abramov: Currently that's a little wonky.
Dan Abramov: You have to use a separate tool to migrate all the image files.
Dan Abramov: I think they're planning to improve this so the migration goes server-to-server.
Dan Abramov: Currently it goes server-to-client-to-server, which is why it's a little strange.
Dan Abramov: Ideally it would be much faster and a smoother process.
Dan Abramov: Once that repository appears on the other server, the last thing that happens is you submit a change to the PLC directory.
Dan Abramov: There's a request that says, "Update my passport—my DID document—to say this is now my hosting."
Dan Abramov: This is now the HTTP endpoint where my content actually lives.
Dan Abramov: That's the last step.
Dan Abramov: That change is then broadcast from the PLC directory.
Dan Abramov: I think the dominant model is that apps cache identities for something like five minutes or an hour.
Dan Abramov: So the next time they resolve your DID they'll see, "Okay, the content is hosted somewhere else."
Dan Abramov: But for most apps they don't even need to do anything because they've already cached all the data by its AT URI.
Dan Abramov: The AT URIs didn't change.
Dan Abramov: If they ever need to refetch something, they can simply go to your new server.
Dan Abramov: So for apps it barely matters because most apps just cache the data.
Theodor Steiner: So basically what I did was...
Theodor Steiner: I had a repo with all my data.
Theodor Steiner: It was on GitHub.
Theodor Steiner: Then I did a Git push to GitLab instead, deleted the old repo on GitHub, and updated my passport to say, "Hey, my data now lives over here."
Dan Abramov: Yeah. That's basically how it works.
Theodor Steiner: And in this repo—you said there's a bunch of JSON living in it—but what kinds of JSON are there?
Dan Abramov: There's actually a great tool to inspect it.
Dan Abramov: It's called **pds.ls**.
Dan Abramov: If you literally type "PDS" as in Personal Data Server, and "ls" as in the Unix `ls` utility for listing files, it'll give you a page where you can input any ATProto handle.
Dan Abramov: You can input your domain if you have an ATProto account associated with it, and it'll show you the whole repository.
Dan Abramov: You'll see collections, which are kind of like folders.
Dan Abramov: If you search for yourself, it'll resolve the DID, resolve the host, and you'll see it says **eurosky.social**.
Dan Abramov: So it resolves where your hosting actually lives.
Dan Abramov: Then these collections are kind of like folders.
Dan Abramov: They're grouped by type.
Dan Abramov: These are all different types of JSON.
Dan Abramov: They're app-specific.
Dan Abramov: The Bluesky app has its own types.
Dan Abramov: npmx has its own types.
Dan Abramov: Every app developer can come up with their own.
Dan Abramov: Nobody is policing them.
Dan Abramov: They're sorted by reverse domain, which naturally gives them unique prefixes.
Dan Abramov: If you work on some app, you just put your app's domain there.
Dan Abramov: It's kind of like a namespace.
Dan Abramov: Almost like scoped packages on npm.
Dan Abramov: And then if you go into any folder, you're going to see a list of JSON files, or records, in that folder that all have the same type.
Dan Abramov: And it's just normal JSON.
Dan Abramov: A like would be a JSON object that says which post was liked, for example.
Dan Abramov: These are going to be links.
Dan Abramov: So if you click into a like, or any specific piece of JSON, there's going to be a specific...
Dan Abramov: For example, this is a like for a certain post. And if you follow the link to the post, you might end up on a different person's repository with the actual post.
Theodor Steiner: Okay, so for the people listening to this podcast, I just navigated to **pds.ls**, and then I put my alias—so my domain, **yoshana.de**—on there and sort of did the DID lookup.
Theodor Steiner: Is that what you call it?
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: The PLC lookup.
Theodor Steiner: And it found my PDS, which in this case is **eurosky.social**.
Theodor Steiner: Below that, we had a bunch of records—no, wait, a bunch of collections.
Theodor Steiner: The collections are all of a certain type, I'd say. And the type is a reverse-domain identifier.
Theodor Steiner: So for Bluesky likes it is `app.bsky.feed.like`.
Theodor Steiner: If I click on that, I get all the likes I ever did on Bluesky.
Theodor Steiner: And if I click even deeper into that, I get the actual JSON.
Theodor Steiner: Here it says it has a timestamp, or `createdAt`, and then it has a subject, which I assume is the target of my like.
Dan Abramov: That's the post.
Theodor Steiner: Why does it have a URI and a CID?
Dan Abramov: Yeah, that's the post you liked.
Theodor Steiner: So URI is the thing we talked about earlier.
Theodor Steiner: This will resolve to somebody else's DID document, and from there we can get the PDS, and from there we can get the collection, and from there we can get the entry—the post in the collection.
Theodor Steiner: But what is the CID here?
Dan Abramov: Yeah. So there are two types of links in ATProto.
Dan Abramov: One is a weak link, or I think it's called the ref, which is just a normal AT URI.
Dan Abramov: And then another one is called a strong link, which is URI and CID.
Dan Abramov: CID is just a hash of the linked record.
Dan Abramov: The idea is that for some links, you maybe want apps to be able to tell: is the thing that it relates to the same as it was?
Dan Abramov: For example, for the like, if the post was edited, does that still count?
Dan Abramov: I think the Bluesky app actually doesn't... I don't know. I don't think it reflects edits. I'm not sure. Maybe it doesn't.
Dan Abramov: So this is an application choice to disregard edits, or it's a product decision.
Dan Abramov: But if they ever allowed edits, this would allow you to say, "Was your like on the version that's there now, or has it changed since the like?"
Theodor Steiner: Okay. So if, for example, I liked a post that said tabs are better than spaces, and then at some point the poster—the author of the post—went back and said spaces are better than tabs, I can point at this record and say no, because the hash changed. Back when I liked it, it was a different post.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: Okay.
Theodor Steiner: And what is the `$type` field here in the JSON?
Dan Abramov: Yeah. So this is the name of the collection it's in.
Dan Abramov: It's a convention that it's always going to be there.
Dan Abramov: So it lets you tell just from the record what kind of record it is without even knowing the URI.
Dan Abramov: It's just the folder name, basically.
Theodor Steiner: So a like would have a very different data structure to, let's say, a post.
Theodor Steiner: How does Bluesky know how to parse those records?
Dan Abramov: Yeah. So this is an interesting question.
Dan Abramov: There are these things called lexicons, which are kind of like type definitions.
Dan Abramov: I really think of them as a lexicon.
Dan Abramov: For each of these types—Bluesky like, Bluesky post, Tangled repo, npmx follow, whatever—each of these things has a schema associated with it, written as JSON.
Dan Abramov: The funny thing is, you don't have to publish them.
Dan Abramov: They're useful for apps because there's tooling that generates actual parsing code and validation, or Zod validation, so that you can safely read it into a typed form in any language.
Dan Abramov: There's JavaScript, Swift, Go, and so on.
Dan Abramov: There are codegen libraries that do this from lexicons.
Dan Abramov: But you can also publish lexicons, and the funny thing is the way you publish them is they're also records.
Theodor Steiner: Mhm. Of course.
Dan Abramov: So you can publish a record with the type definition.
Dan Abramov: And actually, in **pds.ls**, if the type is published, you can click on it as a link and it will show the record.
Dan Abramov: So on the screen you were showing, where you had the like record and it says `$type: app.bsky.feed.like`, if you press on it, there's a lexicon resolution mechanism which says how to find the record that has the schema for this type.
Dan Abramov: And **pds.ls** actually displays it nicely, almost like documentation.
Theodor Steiner: That's pretty cool.
Theodor Steiner: So this is how they allow storing arbitrary data, because there's a way to define how data is structured, and every app gets to define this themselves.
Dan Abramov: Yes.
Dan Abramov: Although it's even more interesting.
Dan Abramov: I think that is the starting point: as a developer, you choose your own formats.
Dan Abramov: But you can also choose to reuse existing ones.
Dan Abramov: You can decide that you're making, maybe, a plugin for Bluesky and then use Bluesky follows as a format for your thing.
Dan Abramov: Or maybe you're making some kind of annotation, like a Community Notes feature or something like this.
Dan Abramov: In that case, maybe it would make sense for Bluesky to do it.
Dan Abramov: But maybe you're making some kind of annotation thing, and then you could allow the target of your annotation to be Bluesky posts, Tangled repos, or anything. You can link to anything.
Dan Abramov: So in that sense, you can use other apps' formats.
Dan Abramov: You can link to them, or you can literally use them as your own format.
Dan Abramov: It's the same as with file formats, right?
Dan Abramov: Many apps use the same format.
Dan Abramov: There's actually been precedent.
Dan Abramov: There are three blogging platforms on ATProto.
Dan Abramov: One is called Leaflet, another Offprint, and another is called pckt.blog.
Dan Abramov: At some point they worked together on a single lexicon because they wanted it to be more interoperable, so that subscriptions from one show up in the other, and so on.
Dan Abramov: They agreed on the format for a publication or a follow.
Dan Abramov: This is called **standard.site**.
Dan Abramov: It's become a bigger thing than this. It's kind of like RSS on ATProto in a sense.
Dan Abramov: The funny thing is now you can also adopt standard.site for your own blog that's not hosted on any of these platforms, and create records describing your post, your publication, and your brand colors in the publication.
Dan Abramov: And links to any standard.site posts in the Bluesky app will be shown with a special treatment, with a box that has the branding color of your site.
Dan Abramov: So this is an example where three different blogging platforms decided to share a lexicon, and then the Bluesky app decided to read that lexicon and use the information from it.
Dan Abramov: In that sense, it's a much more dynamic ecosystem where some things get standardized, in a sense, but completely community-driven.
Theodor Steiner: This is kind of wild.
Theodor Steiner: This is like I built my own app, and to kickstart it, I let my users post from my app to Instagram.
Theodor Steiner: I let them post pictures to Instagram, and I can also display every picture they posted to Instagram.
Theodor Steiner: Yeah, this is the moment where it kind of clicks.
Dan Abramov: Yeah. Well, the other thing is you can index things of different types, right?
Dan Abramov: Of course, indexing all Bluesky posts is crazy in terms of volume, so that's expensive.
Dan Abramov: But you could maybe index something that relates to the user.
Dan Abramov: And then you can do these kinds of mashups.
Dan Abramov: There's another funny example.
Dan Abramov: There's this lexicon—do you know Last.fm, the music tracking thing?
Theodor Steiner: Yeah, I've heard of that.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Dan Abramov: So there's a lexicon called **Teal FM play**.
Dan Abramov: Teal FM was supposed to be something where you track your music usage, but I don't think they've launched yet. It's been in development for a long time, but they're doing it on weekends.
Dan Abramov: So they still haven't launched the actual website or the app.
Dan Abramov: But it doesn't matter because the lexicon exists.
Dan Abramov: They already made tooling to submit what you're listening to, even though there is no app.
Dan Abramov: You're just writing records of this lexicon.
Dan Abramov: And so people have already made third-party apps that display your listening stats on Teal FM, even though Teal FM does not exist.
Dan Abramov: It's kind of funny.
Dan Abramov: You can show aggregations across it, like top listened artists on Teal FM.
Dan Abramov: But again, there's no Teal FM.
Dan Abramov: The way I think about it is: if you had the world's JSON, why not run joins over products?
Dan Abramov: You can do things like top tracks that your follows on Bluesky have been listening to.
Dan Abramov: Or you can ask: what are the trending repositories from your friends?
Dan Abramov: You can combine data from different apps and cross-join it.
Dan Abramov: That feels like the web to me.
Dan Abramov: It's taking the web idea and turning it into a web database.
Dan Abramov: I don't know.
Dan Abramov: It's breaking the boundaries, or blurring the boundaries, between apps, and making it more like there's the web of data, and the apps are just lenses through which we look at the data.
Dan Abramov: And these lenses can be... anyone can create a new one.
Theodor Steiner: And posting records across products sounds kind of crazy at first, but since it's the AT Protocol—Authenticated Transfer—that means you have authenticated everything that is posted to your repo, and that's why it's safe to post across apps, right?
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Dan Abramov: So the way this works is apps can be sure that the content is really yours because they can always resolve it through the AT Protocol.
Dan Abramov: They go to your hosting, and your hosting returns them the thing.
Dan Abramov: It is signed with the key that they can verify is the key in your DID document.
Dan Abramov: And then the other clever thing they do is that you need to somehow scale up the network.
Dan Abramov: You can imagine for each user there is hosting.
Dan Abramov: Of course, a lot of users are going to be on the same hosting.
Dan Abramov: Hosting can range from hosting 100,000 users to maybe a solo user hosting. Both of these are valid.
Dan Abramov: But that's where the data lives.
Dan Abramov: Then you somehow need it to flow into all the apps, right?
Dan Abramov: And it's inconvenient for apps to...
Dan Abramov: You don't want them to smash all the hosting all the time to figure out what happened.
Dan Abramov: So apps maintain caches and subscribe through WebSocket.
Dan Abramov: But then there's a question of: how do you scale it further?
Dan Abramov: You want some shared infrastructure.
Dan Abramov: You want shared caches. You want shared retransmission.
Dan Abramov: Ideally, there should be a way to just subscribe over WebSocket to one event bus that has information about everything that happens on the network, or a subset that's relevant to your app—maybe your app's collection types and so on.
Dan Abramov: The clever thing they did is that you can build retransmitters like this.
Dan Abramov: They're called relays.
Dan Abramov: Bluesky runs one. There are a bunch of community-run relays that let you subscribe over WebSocket to everything that happens on the network.
Dan Abramov: The stream that is passed is a stream of commits.
Dan Abramov: It's a stream of events about commits, identity changes, and so on.
Dan Abramov: And the stream is transmitted with proofs.
Dan Abramov: The stream contains signed commits.
Dan Abramov: So each commit is signed.
Dan Abramov: You actually don't need to trust the retransmitter.
Dan Abramov: That's another big idea.
Dan Abramov: Because cryptography is woven into it, you don't need to trust it.
Dan Abramov: You can build community retransmitters and these nodes, and not have to worry that they're modifying the content as it flows through them.
Dan Abramov: So that's the authenticated part in it.
Theodor Steiner: So if I try to recap this for my understanding:
Theodor Steiner: You have a very weird distribution of Personal Data Servers.
Theodor Steiner: There are some with millions of users—probably the Bluesky ones—and then there are people who host it in their basement.
Theodor Steiner: And to not have every app know every PDS, go there every time, and pull them all the time, you have those relay services.
Theodor Steiner: I imagine it's a super beefy server somewhere that somehow knows all PDSs and subscribes to all of them.
Theodor Steiner: Then it's just like a huge Apache Kafka, and they pipe the events into the web.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Dan Abramov: I don't think it needs to be super beefy.
Dan Abramov: I'm not sure, but in terms of cost, I think it's something around 30 bucks a month to run it at the current volume.
Dan Abramov: But yeah, they need to know the PDSs on the network, which is a bit wonky because how do you know?
Dan Abramov: There are a bunch of ways.
Dan Abramov: One is that you can enumerate them.
Dan Abramov: I think there is an endpoint on existing relays to enumerate the ones that they know.
Dan Abramov: That's how you can bootstrap.
Dan Abramov: A PDS can also request to be crawled.
Dan Abramov: So if you put a new PDS online, you can add some known relays to ping them.
Dan Abramov: And then it can also discover it through links.
Dan Abramov: If it sees a link to a PDS it hasn't seen before, and that resolves to a PDS it hasn't seen before, it can decide to crawl it.
Dan Abramov: So it's kind of up to the relay how to do it.
Dan Abramov: And if it wants to just provide an archive or only retransmit and have no archive—because keeping an archive is kind of expensive...
Theodor Steiner: So if I want to build on ATProto, I have this shared data layer, and I have apps that are already quite successful that populate that data layer with users.
Theodor Steiner: Those users use those apps and therefore populate it with their own records.
Theodor Steiner: And if I want to build on that, I would probably get one of those relays and start downloading data from there, putting it into my own database.
Theodor Steiner: Is that how it works?
Theodor Steiner: And then I run queries and my app logic on that?
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Dan Abramov: So I think the exact way you do it depends on what data your app is going to care about.
Dan Abramov: If it only cares about its own data—if you came up with new record types and that's the stuff that your app displays—then you don't need to backfill it because it doesn't exist.
Dan Abramov: So if you just connect and start listening to a relay, and you filter it down to the stuff that your app cares about, then once records start getting created, you will have all of them.
Dan Abramov: You don't actually need to get anything that existed before.
Dan Abramov: That's the easy path.
Dan Abramov: Then you just have a connection to this thing, and you keep track of where your users are.
Dan Abramov: If you want to do something with existing data, then you have to backfill it.
Dan Abramov: There are really two ways to go about it.
Dan Abramov: The way I'm talking about is: if you want data to be in your own database, then of course you have to somehow get it there.
Dan Abramov: Then the question is: is it from a big app or a small app?
Dan Abramov: Because if it's something like Tangled, you can probably backfill all records from all Tangled users in a reasonable time because there's just not that much.
Dan Abramov: Maybe 50,000 records. I don't know how many, but it's not that much.
Dan Abramov: Or Teal FM.
Dan Abramov: Okay, maybe a lot of records because people do scrobble. It's probably millions now.
Dan Abramov: But essentially, you just need to find all the...
Dan Abramov: I think maybe the relay has an API for this, but there's a way to find out which users or identities have a collection of a certain type.
Dan Abramov: So you can figure out who the users of a particular app are and then just get their stuff.
Dan Abramov: There are tools that do this.
Dan Abramov: There's something called **TAP**, which is their tool for backfill.
Dan Abramov: You tell it which collections to look for, and it will try to synchronize it all and then listen to new events.
Dan Abramov: But there's also a different approach.
Dan Abramov: Especially if you want Bluesky, you probably don't want to download terabytes of all Bluesky posts that ever existed.
Dan Abramov: But maybe you want to build some app on top of Bluesky.
Dan Abramov: Of course, you can use the Bluesky API.
Dan Abramov: That's the traditional way, but I think it's a bit not ATProto-spirited, right?
Dan Abramov: You rely on somebody else's app-specific thing.
Dan Abramov: But there's a tool called **Constellation**.
Dan Abramov: It's community-run.
Dan Abramov: It's a server run by the community that indexes all the records and provides an API for backlinks.
Dan Abramov: So it lets you say, given this post, give me all records that link to it.
Dan Abramov: That means you can get all the likes of a post, all followers of a person, all quotes.
Dan Abramov: It's kind of like going through the primary-foreign-key query.
Dan Abramov: You ask: what are all the things that link to this piece of JSON?
Dan Abramov: This actually lets you build a workable app without a backend, because you can hit the user's hosting if you need something user-specific, and then you can hit Constellation if you need to go one step removed and see all the things that link to this.
Dan Abramov: This is less efficient, but you don't need a backend at all.
Theodor Steiner: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: So the more I hear about this, at first I thought AT Protocol was really complicated.
Theodor Steiner: But now I understand why it needs to be complicated, because it collapses the stack.
Theodor Steiner: My app needs less and less.
Theodor Steiner: It doesn't need a data layer necessarily, because every user has their own data layer, and I can use the existing relays and everything to aggregate that.
Theodor Steiner: Then it doesn't need an authentication layer, because the user has—is it called an atmosphere account?
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Dan Abramov: So it's kind of funny because it uses OAuth, right?
Dan Abramov: You log in through OAuth, but the OAuth provider is actually your PDS.
Dan Abramov: So in a sense, it's almost like logging into a Google account, except you are Google.
Dan Abramov: It's your hosting.
Dan Abramov: This is why, if you change to **eurosky.social**, when you click "login through atmosphere" in other apps, it's going to show the eurosky.social login page now, because that is now your hosting.
Theodor Steiner: Yeah, the domain is eurosky.social, and that's where I log in.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: Super interesting.
Dan Abramov: So it's lifting identity and the data.
Dan Abramov: I think of it as the people-centric data layer for the web.
Theodor Steiner: That also brings its own complexity though, right?
Theodor Steiner: For example, let's just take an Instagram competitor.
Theodor Steiner: You want to build that app, and it's slow, and you want to debug or improve performance.
Theodor Steiner: But the problem could be outside of your product.
Theodor Steiner: It could be the user's PDS being really slow or laggy.
Theodor Steiner: It could be the relay struggling to aggregate the data.
Theodor Steiner: How do people cope with that?
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Dan Abramov: I think with hosting itself, the idea is pretty resilient to that.
Dan Abramov: If you want a good app, you just shouldn't really go to hosting much, because you aggregate things as they come in.
Dan Abramov: So the hosting just emits events.
Dan Abramov: You shouldn't blast the hosting with a thousand requests.
Dan Abramov: You serve everything from your database or from the stuff that you've cached.
Dan Abramov: So hosting being a bit wonky is actually fine, as long as it actually emits the events that it should generate.
Dan Abramov: That isn't really a major problem.
Dan Abramov: It's just a server that serves some JSON, so it shouldn't really get laggy.
Dan Abramov: Of course, for users who are on Bluesky, if Bluesky is having scaling issues, then that does reflect in the app.
Dan Abramov: Some events might struggle to come through.
Dan Abramov: The relay might struggle.
Dan Abramov: This is something you just kind of live with.
Dan Abramov: Your app is more webby, so there are more things that could go wrong.
Dan Abramov: The relay itself—again, if you rely on the one run by Bluesky, it's mostly working fine.
Dan Abramov: I think there have been incidents, but it's mostly working fine.
Dan Abramov: If you don't trust it, you can definitely run your own, and that is how you completely isolate yourself from problems upstream.
Dan Abramov: There were also cases where other apps that run their own relays or used the community relay were up when the Bluesky app was not working, because there was some relay problem.
Dan Abramov: I think with time...
Dan Abramov: Right now it's the early adopter stage, where you run it because you believe there is a better way to do web products.
Dan Abramov: I think of it as open source in the 90s.
Dan Abramov: People would tell you you're crazy, or Microsoft says it's cancer, and then 10 years later Microsoft is actually running on open source.
Dan Abramov: So I think right now we're at that stage where people tell you you're crazy.
Dan Abramov: These are early adopter pains.
Dan Abramov: But because it's a standard, everything that benefits some apps can benefit others because they speak the same language.
Dan Abramov: There's shared infrastructure, shared libraries, shared tools, different kinds of things you can do with it.
Dan Abramov: As that infrastructure grows and becomes more reusable, the network will become more resilient in general.
Dan Abramov: There will be more relay options.
Dan Abramov: It'll be easier to backfill.
Dan Abramov: There will be archives for rehydrating everything if you lose some data.
Dan Abramov: So I think we'll see more of that.
Theodor Steiner: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: I actually just thought of a really interesting problem concerning sustainability.
Theodor Steiner: You talked about Bluesky being both the app layer and the PDS layer.
Theodor Steiner: For Bluesky, I can clearly see a path to monetization.
Theodor Steiner: They have the app layer, and it would be quite easy for them to monetize that.
Theodor Steiner: Let's say display ads or premium accounts.
Theodor Steiner: But there are PDSs that don't have an app layer, and I'd say they bear most of the cost because they have the egress and hosting costs.
Theodor Steiner: Is there a way for apps to give back to the PDSs, or somehow shift the weight of that cost structure?
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Dan Abramov: I'm not sure.
Dan Abramov: I think running an app is many times more expensive than running hosting.
Dan Abramov: I'm not 100% sure, but first, the app serves the users.
Dan Abramov: If you have a million daily users, that's the load that goes into the app.
Dan Abramov: The hosting serves the apps.
Dan Abramov: So that's actually much more distributed already.
Dan Abramov: Especially if there are different hosts.
Dan Abramov: If you self-host, you really only serve your own data.
Dan Abramov: Compared to something like Mastodon, where if your post goes viral, all the instances are going to hammer your instance.
Dan Abramov: Here it doesn't really matter that much because the app shields you.
Dan Abramov: The other thing is that I think hosting is still such a novel concept.
Dan Abramov: Usually you have hosting if you have a website or a company.
Dan Abramov: But as part of your internet experience, even if you log in with a Google account, that's kind of the relationship you have to Google.
Dan Abramov: The idea is that we can lift this up and make it transferable.
Dan Abramov: I think it's kind of new.
Dan Abramov: There's a Dropbox with all your social data.
Dan Abramov: That's kind of a new idea.
Dan Abramov: I don't think it's even recognized by mainstream users at this moment.
Dan Abramov: Maybe in five years, or maybe in ten years, it will be.
Dan Abramov: But hosting can also offer services.
Dan Abramov: I'd actually pay for safe backups.
Dan Abramov: I'd really want my hosting provider to periodically back up all my data without me thinking about it.
Dan Abramov: That could be one thing.
Dan Abramov: Some people might want more storage, maybe for videos and things like that.
Dan Abramov: But in general, I think it's actually the app that's much more expensive.
Dan Abramov: Things like CDNs, video transcoding, serving lots of video—all of that is way more expensive than serving JSON.
Dan Abramov: That's where I think a lot of the costs actually go.
Theodor Steiner: So you're saying that in order to run a stable app, you want to shield the PDSs from your app layer anyway.
Theodor Steiner: And shielding the PDSs will take most of the load off the PDSs and onto your app layer.
Theodor Steiner: So it's sort of a self-restraining system.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Dan Abramov: Because you want it to be reliable.
Dan Abramov: If a PDS is misbehaving, you don't want that to reflect in the app.
Dan Abramov: Past a certain level of product complexity, you just have to have a database.
Dan Abramov: Or you can hit community caches, but they're shielding you.
Dan Abramov: If you hit Constellation, that also shields hosting because Constellation has a cache of everything that it has indexed.
Theodor Steiner: Interesting.
Theodor Steiner: So what would you say is currently still missing from the AT Protocol?
Theodor Steiner: Is there something that's not here yet?
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Dan Abramov: There are a lot of rough edges in terms of developer experience, or what the right way to do something is.
Dan Abramov: People are still experimenting.
Dan Abramov: But I think the big thing the team is currently working on is permissioned data.
Dan Abramov: Right now, ATProto is fully focused on public data, which I think was the right focus.
Dan Abramov: If you start with private data, that's a much smaller scale.
Dan Abramov: You don't know that you're going to scale up to public.
Dan Abramov: Whereas if you scale up to public, you have to figure out aggregation and all these things efficiently.
Dan Abramov: Then you can scale down to permissioned data.
Dan Abramov: So they're working on extending the protocol—or maybe having a sibling protocol—for stuff that isn't meant for public retransmission.
Dan Abramov: Things like groups.
Dan Abramov: Not messaging, because for that you really want end-to-end encryption, and that's an entirely separate thing.
Dan Abramov: You could still use part of the identity layer, but it's a separate problem.
Dan Abramov: Whereas things that are gated by membership aren't completely private, because any app that has been granted access still needs to see them in order to display them.
Dan Abramov: So they're working on this permissioned-data extension to the protocol.
Dan Abramov: Right now, if you want something private or group-private, you can do it with your own database.
Dan Abramov: Which is also okay.
Dan Abramov: ATProto is pragmatic in the sense that you can adopt just the parts that make sense to you.
Dan Abramov: You can use only the identity layer and keep everything else in your own database.
Dan Abramov: Ideally you'd move towards "ATProto-ing" it a bit more.
Dan Abramov: But then you run into the wall where group-level stuff, user preferences, and things like that have to live somewhere.
Dan Abramov: There's a hacky thing where I think you can store some of it in Bluesky preferences.
Dan Abramov: But anyway, there's no good API for private or protected data.
Dan Abramov: That's what they're working on.
Dan Abramov: I think that's the biggest gap.
Dan Abramov: There's currently no protocol-native way to do that.
Theodor Steiner: So this might be a sacrilege in a podcast with a React core member, but I'm a huge fan of Svelte.
Theodor Steiner: In the ATProto world, quite a few apps seem to be built with Svelte.
Theodor Steiner: There's someone—or maybe a group of people—trying to build a Discord clone based on ATProto.
Theodor Steiner: I think it's called Roomy Chat or something.
Dan Abramov: Yeah. Yes.
Theodor Steiner: And they seem to be stuck on having private servers because they don't have permissioned data yet.
Theodor Steiner: Having permissioned data would unlock that for them because they could have data being created behind access controls.
Dan Abramov: Yeah, probably.
Dan Abramov: I think so.
Dan Abramov: Things like chats are just a different modality because they're kind of ephemeral.
Dan Abramov: Maybe for Discord you do want to keep it, but I don't know that you necessarily want every chat message to be a record.
Dan Abramov: I don't know if that makes sense.
Dan Abramov: But having permissioned data would definitely help.
Dan Abramov: Svelte is really popular in that part of the community.
Dan Abramov: I'm not sure why.
Dan Abramov: Maybe it just fits the ethos.
Dan Abramov: It's kind of webby.
Dan Abramov: It has the connotation of being the lighter thing, the newer thing.
Dan Abramov: And React is like Java to these people.
Dan Abramov: Which is okay.
Dan Abramov: I'll take it.
Dan Abramov: Whatever works.
Theodor Steiner: It might just be a function of Svelte adopters being early adopters, and then ATProto also being quite early.
Dan Abramov: Maybe. Yeah.
Dan Abramov: But I think a lot of it is aesthetic.
Dan Abramov: It feels webby, and ATProto is also very webby.
Dan Abramov: So I think there's a match there.
Theodor Steiner: Okay, I think we covered so much ground in this episode.
Theodor Steiner: Is there anything left to say?
Theodor Steiner: Anything that we haven't covered yet?
Dan Abramov: I don't know.
Dan Abramov: I would encourage more people to actually try Bluesky for real—for posting the stuff you would normally post on Twitter.
Dan Abramov: One thing I would encourage is to actually...
Dan Abramov: The default feed, I think, is called Discover, and I don't think it's very good.
Dan Abramov: There is a very good custom feed called **For You**, literally like the "For You" feed on Twitter.
Dan Abramov: If you go to the Feeds tab in the Bluesky app and search for it, you'll find it.
Dan Abramov: I highly recommend it.
Dan Abramov: It learns from your likes and from what people who liked the same things as you have also liked.
Dan Abramov: I honestly feel it's about as good as the Twitter algorithm used to be.
Dan Abramov: I always use that feed.
Dan Abramov: The other funny thing is that this feed literally runs from somebody's gaming computer at home.
Dan Abramov: Again, because what is a feed?
Dan Abramov: It's just an HTTP service that returns an array of AT URIs for posts.
Dan Abramov: Everything in the network is identified by an AT URI, so it doesn't matter where it's hosted.
Dan Abramov: You can build these services because they're all talking about the same thing.
Dan Abramov: This For You feed just returns an array of AT URIs, paginates through them, and then the Bluesky app talks to that feed, gets the URIs, and hydrates them from the database into actual posts.
Dan Abramov: It's very cool that you can have userland feeds on Bluesky.
Dan Abramov: I think this is the best one.
Dan Abramov: Especially if you're trying to get people to move over and try Bluesky, just tell them to install the For You feed because it's simply better.
Theodor Steiner: I'm also on For You.
Theodor Steiner: And it's super funny because sometimes the person who hosts the feed goes down for an hour, and then it comes back up and he posts something like, "Sorry, I had to upgrade my PC. I put more RAM into it."
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: It's very hacky-cool.
Theodor Steiner: Okay.
Theodor Steiner: I think that's it for today then.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: Thank you so much for coming on and talking about ATProto.
Theodor Steiner: I mean, you obviously couldn't say it yourself, but probably the best way to learn about ATProto is your blog.
Theodor Steiner: You have a whole series of blog posts on ATProto and how it works, using different ways to break it down.
Theodor Steiner: I think the file system one is great.
Theodor Steiner: Then go on Bluesky and just start following a bunch of people.
Theodor Steiner: My personal recommendation would be the Starter Packs.
Theodor Steiner: They let you, with just one click, follow everyone in your area of interest.
Dan Abramov: Yeah.
Theodor Steiner: For example, I assume you'd be in the React Starter Pack, or the Web Dev Starter Pack.
Dan Abramov: Yeah. Probably, if there is one.
Dan Abramov: There's definitely one for JavaScript.
Theodor Steiner: I'm in the Svelte Starter Pack, which was really cool because it got me bootstrapped with a whole bunch of likes, which I was really happy about.
Dan Abramov: All right.
Theodor Steiner: And actually, this show is also on Bluesky—or if it isn't yet, I'll make sure it will be after this post.
Theodor Steiner: You can always check us on the regular HTTP web.
Theodor Steiner: Our domain is **uit-inside.linecorp.com**.
Theodor Steiner: Make sure to follow Dan if you don't already.
Theodor Steiner: And thank you so much for listening.
Theodor Steiner: If you want to listen to other episodes, most of them are in Japanese, but I think there are three or four English episodes out there.
Theodor Steiner: So just look for them.
Theodor Steiner: Or maybe study Japanese.
Theodor Steiner: Or use a tool to translate them.
Theodor Steiner: Thank you so much for coming on.
Theodor Steiner: Bye-bye.
Dan Abramov: Thank you.